the president is threatening officials
in North Carolina over the upcoming
Republican National Convention scheduled
to be held there Paula Reed is at the
white house for us
Paula good morning a lot of questions
about these conventions what does the
president want good morning Tony
president Trump is pressing the state of
North Carolina to get back to business
by insisting that the state's Democratic
governor guarantee that thousands of GOP
delegates will be able to attend the
Republican convention currently
scheduled for August and if not he may
move the lucrative event to a different
state the president tweeted that the
state's Democratic governor Roy Cooper
is still in shutdown mood and said that
if the governor can't guarantee that
convention goers will be allowed to
fully occupy the arena in Charlotte
they'll have to find another one North
Carolina has nearly 24,000 Cove aid
cases and the number of people
hospitalized just reached a new high a
spokesperson for the governor said that
the state will be relying on data and
science as officials review convention
plans with the RNC the president's push
for the country to reopen comes as the
administration told Congress it would
purchase 100 million swabs by the end of
the year but doubled down on its
position that leaves states responsible
for planning and carrying out the tests
President Trump
briefly put aside partisan threats
during a series of events yesterday to
mark Memorial Day
visiting Arlington National Cemetery for
a wreath-laying and calling on Americans
to honor fallen soldiers and those lost
to coronavirus at Fort McHenry in
Baltimore we will vanquish the virus and
America will rise from this crisis to
new and even greater heights though many
attendees at the Memorial Day event
swore CDC recommended masks as did
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo the
president did not his Democratic rival
former Vice President Joe Biden did wear
a mask as he visited a Delaware Veterans
Memorial on Monday it was the first time
the likely Democratic presidential
nominee made an appearance outside of
his Delaware home in nearly two months
service President Trump
shared a tweet with this picture
criticizing Joe Biden for wearing a mask
even as the u.s. reaches the grim
milestone of 100,000 Cova deaths a
marker the president once said he hoped
the country would never see Anthony
Paula thank you